On July 5th, the White House posted this seemingly
uncontroversial and unremarkable Tweet —
a list of places it had donated vaccines.
It seemed like a banal government press release
few would give much thought to.
That is, until it was suddenly deleted — and
for fear of causing an international incident,
no less.
See if you can find why.
The problem was not the actual donation.
Nor was it the mere reference to “Taiwan”
— a word the U.S. government uses all the
time.
And nowhere in the Tweet were the words “country”
or “nation”.
No, the concern was about this tiny flag,
which the White House called an “honest
mistake”.
So fragile is this issue that merely tweeting
an icon of a flag might be interpreted as
a change in policy, or even a recognition
of statehood — something that could trigger
a military response by China.
And yet so too could deleting the Tweet cause
confusion.
Afterward, the Taiwanese Foreign Ministry
asked the U.S. not to “cause unnecessary
speculation” after its president and de
facto ambassador were left retweeting a message
now deleted.
This was not the first such diplomatic mishap,
nor, surely, will it be the last.
The U.S. government practices a strategy of
deliberate ambiguity, leading much of the
public, many in the media, and even a few
politicians to misunderstand its position.
Despite what China would have you believe,
the U.S. does not, in fact, adhere to the
“One-China” Principle.
Neither does it support Taiwanese independence,
though it does have “unofficial” relations
with its government.
The reality is much more complicated...
Sponsored by Morning Brew — the free, daily
newsletter I read to stay up to date on the
world of tech and business.
When Mao Zedong founded the People’s Republic
of China in 1949 and promised to quote “liberate”
Taiwan, the U.S. initially decided not to
intervene.
Only after the invasion of South Korea in
the summer of 1950 did the Truman administration
begin recognizing the strategic value of Taiwan.
Four years later, in 1954, the U.S. signed
a defense treaty, promising to protect Taiwan
if attacked.
This, along with America’s refusal to recognize
the PRC, lasted for another 25 years, until
it discovered a bigger threat: The Soviet
Union.
Largely in response to the Communists up North,
America finally recognized the People’s
Republic in 1979 as the, quote, “sole legal
Government of China.”
It promised not to pursue a “two Chinas”
or “One China, one Taiwan” solution, which
meant ending official relations with Taiwan.
It also stated, in a communiqué, “...the
United States of America acknowledges the
Chinese position that there is but one China
and Taiwan is part of China”
Upon hearing this, you, like many people,
might conclude that the U.S. acquiesced to
the People’s Republic.
But if so, you’re not paying close enough
attention.
It recognizes the PRC as the “sole legal
government of China” but doesn’t define
what China is.
Remember, Taiwan is formally known as the
“Republic of China”, and both claimed
to be “China”.
On the other hand, it merely acknowledges
“...the Chinese position that there is but
one China and Taiwan is part of China”.
The key word here being “acknowledge”
— which is not the same as “accept”
or “recognize”.
It does, however, give a similar impression
— at least on a cursory reading.
And this is certainly no accident.
The American position then and now is to obfuscate
— to narrowly satisfy China’s stringent
demands while giving up as little as possible
in the process.
The U.S. could argue it fulfilled its obligations,
while China could argue the U.S. fully agreed
to its position.
A mutually enforced facade of resolution.
In reality, nothing said or done back in ‘79
truly resolved the issue.
Both sides only kicked the can further down
the road.
And far worse than simply delaying that ugly
conversation, the talks created the superficial
illusion of agreement, leading to hurt feelings
and accusations later on.
In other words: America spoke as vaguely as
possible, which China gladly exploited.
The Chinese translation of the document, for
example, uses a word closer in meaning to
“recognize”, despite there being an accurate
translation of “acknowledge” available.
It’s quite possible that many in China and
even Taiwan, most of whom read the document
in Chinese, believe the U.S. promised more
than it actually did.
That was, after all, kind of the point.
There’s another, similar linguistic misconception.
The “One-China Principle” is the term
for China’s position — that Taiwan is
a part of the People’s Republic.
This is not the same as generic, lower-case
“One-China policies” — which every country
has a different version of.
When China accuses another country of violating
the “One-China Principle”, it’s really
only saying that it disagrees with the action,
not that the other country has broken a promise.
Make no mistake: The U.S. does not adhere
to the Principle, only to its own policy — one
which has gone unchanged for over forty years.
the People’s Republic, the U.S. ended its
defense treaty with Taiwan, replacing it instead
with the Taiwan Relations Act.
The TRA was designed to reassume Taiwan by
providing it with the weapons it needs to
defend itself.
And while it states an expectation that the
issue will be resolved peacefully, it does
not guarantee military support, only that
the President will inform Congress of any
potential threat, and then take “appropriate
action”.
Still, all parties operated under the assumption
of eventual unification.
All that changed in the 90s, as Taiwan transitioned
from brutal authoritarian rule to what is
today one of the strongest and most vibrant
democracies on earth.
The process was neither smooth nor easy, and
made advocating for independence legal, complicating
the situation.
Today the future status of Taiwan is still
the primary issue that divides parties.
On one side are the “Blues”, who favor
closer economic ties to China.
China buys nearly half of Taiwan’s exports,
which they see as a critical relationship
to maintain.
To them, China is less an adversary and more
a business partner.
The dominant party in this camp is the Kuomintang,
or KMT.
On the other side are the “Greens”, led
by the Democratic Progressive Party, DPP.
Greens see trade with China as a dangerous
dependency that leads to economic coercion.
They prefer the term “Taiwan” to “The
Republic of China”.
But while the KMT is sometimes sloppily labeled
“pro-unification”, and the DPP “pro-independence”,
this is simply not true.
In reality, both sides agree that maintaining
the status quo is the best short-to-medium
term strategy, and neither side, except for
a few radicals, advocates unification or independence.
The Greens argue Taiwan is already an independent,
sovereign state, and thus has no reason to
declare independence — something which would
surely start a war.
None of this is meant to discount the ferocity
of Taiwanese politics — healthy democracy
is fierce and messy — but to highlight how
subtle their differences.
This graph helps put things in perspective.
When asked their preferences, the Taiwanese
public has answered remarkably consistently
for twenty years.
The top three responses are all “maintain
the status quo”, and only differ in the
long term.
28% prefer to “decide at a later date”,
27% wish to maintain the status quo indefinitely,
and one quarter wish to “maintain the status
quo but move toward independence”.
Only a small minority wish to unify immediately,
move toward unification, or declare independence
as soon as possible.
Ironically, it’s most often Americans, halfway
across the globe, who panic when China flies
fighter jets through Taiwanese airspace, not
the Taiwanese public, for whom such shows
of intimidation have become mundane.
Most are content simply keeping things as
they are.
As is the United States.
Officially, it “does not support” independence.
But remember: American diplomats are precise
in their meaning.
The U.S. does not say it opposes independence,
which would mean taking a position.
But while it does not take a stance on the
outcome, it does advocate for the process.
Not only does it oppose a forceful unification
by China, but so too does it oppose a unilateral
declaration of independence by Taiwan — something
which would also destabilize the region.
When Taiwan’s president proposed a public
referendum on independence in 2003, the U.S.
was caught between a rock and a hard place.
On one hand, it did not support what it perceived
as dangerous antagonizing.
On the other, it did not want to publicly
oppose a legal, democratic process.
Instead, it reiterated indirectly, but unequivocally,
that it did not support independence — sending
the message that the president had crossed
a line.
Since then, Taiwanese officials have gone
out of their way to prove they don’t plan
on rocking the boat.
In 2018, current President Tsai Ing-Wen stayed
silent on a referendum calling for its Olympic
name to be changed from “Chinese-Taipei”
to “Taiwan”.
And she’s in the Green camp.
Every major politician today understands the
need to proceed with caution — repeating,
sometimes monotonously, that they won’t
pursue independence.
That doesn’t stop China from claiming they
support independence, however, which engenders
Nationalism at home and helps narrow the boundaries
of what’s “acceptable”.
But things can’t continue like this forever.
While America and Taiwan support the status
quo for now, everyone agrees it’s untenable
in the long term.
One of three red lines China says the crossing
of which would trigger an attack, is if Taiwan
refuses to ever consider negotiating unification.
The possibility of change — however minuscule
— is thus imperative to maintaining the
peaceful status quo.
The question is: in what direction does time
favor?
In terms of public opinion, the answer is
clear.
When broken down by age, it’s evident that
younger generations feel an increasingly strong
Taiwanese identity distinct from China.
The 2014 Sunflower Movement demonstrated how
determined young people are, which recent
developments in Hong Kong will surely only
convince them of more so.
And yet, every day China’s military and
economy grow stronger.
It may believe time is on its side — that
the balance of power will only shift in its
favor.
Likewise, does it surely notice America’s
growing disinterest in acting as the world’s
police force.
China may doubt the will of Americans to fight
a war so distant at a time when it’s so
preoccupied at home.
In the meantime, Taiwan is stuck in a historically
unprecedented limbo.
A weird in-between state in which it can enjoy
freedom only if it pretends not to,
A status quo that has somehow survived eight
American administrations, forty years, and
yet can suddenly be called into question with
a mere icon of flag in a Tweet.
You may wonder where I find the ideas for
these videos.
Instead of reading traditional news, which
is too often dry, sensationalist, and irrelevant,
I try to consume less but higher quality news,
and today’s sponsor, Morning Brew, is one
of the few sources I’ve read every single
day — now for about 6 months, long before
they started sponsoring the channel.
Morning Brew is a daily newsletter that covers
topics like tech, business, and finance — in
other words, it’s kind of the perfect fit
for anyone who enjoys these videos.
I find it’s a good way of staying up to
date on a wide cross-section of different
topics — one edition may feature a concise
summary of the most important news story of
the day, followed by some fascinating statistics,
and a few links to the best articles, videos,
or Tweets of the week.
Best of all, Morning Brew is completely, 100%
free.
There’s no trial, or premium upgrade, just
a concise daily newsletter delivered to your
inbox each morning.
You can sign up in about 15 seconds just by
clicking the button you see on screen now.